[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hello.
First, I'm going to talk
briefly before I read my poems.
And my talk is inspired
by my Radcliffe Fellow
Fellows, many of
whom have expressed
to me over the past
nine months or so--
me, the lone poet
in the cohort--
that they wish that they
understood poetry better,
its meaning and its purpose.
I remember being out on
the lawn in Radcliffe yard
on a sunny September
day early on,
and one of these 50 fascinating
people who I had just met
was standing behind me
in the barbecue line.
And he asked me, how do
you know if a poem is good?
And I don't think I had a very
good answer to that question,
if I was able to answer at all.
I really don't remember.
But what I wish I had
said was, I don't.
Isn't that wonderful?
Because the first thing
that I want to say
about poetry is that a poem
is an utterly free space
for language, the only utterly
free space for language
that I'm aware of.
And that is what makes
it indispensable to me,
and also what
makes it political.
When I first considered
what I wanted
to say about poetry to potential
readers who had not yet
found their way
there, my impulse
was to write a manifesto
or even a rant.
But then I thought maybe that
we hear quite enough ranting
these days.
And maybe the rant is devalued
right now, like a currency.
So maybe another mode I
felt would be more useful
and buy more.
So I decided instead to
ask some questions, which
is poetry's most important job
anyway, to get you to listen
and to get you to wonder.
So who really
listens to a shouter,
and who wonders on command?
It's my hope that
questions, like a poem,
will be more effective
in getting the mind
to participate in making
the meaning of what I want
to see here, because
another thing
that I believe about
poems is that they,
more than any
other kind of text,
invite or even demand
that their readers lean in
and become active participants
in the joyful task of making
meaning, another reason why
reading or writing poetry
is a political action.
Before I get to the
questions, I want
to point out that poetry
seems to get attention
in the mainstream culture in
only two sets of circumstances.
First, every year or so, The
New York Times or The Atlantic
or some other media outlet
with cultural prestige
features an article
with a title like,
"Does Poetry Matter,"
or "Can Poetry Matter,"
or "Why Doesn't Poetry
Matter Anymore?"
And then the second
set of circumstances
is in times of public
trauma or crisis,
like our current trauma or
like the aftermath of 9/11,
The New York Times
or The Atlantic
or some other media outlet
with cultural prestige features
an article with a blunt
title like, "Americans Turn
to Poetry in Times of
Crisis," as if to keep us
from panicking, it's
time to break out
the poems like expired
Ativans that have been sitting
in the nightstand drawer.
Both kinds of articles
diminish the value of poetry.
And if my questions do take
a ranting or political tone,
it's this mainstream
diminishment
that I'm talking back to.
After all, The New York
Times never asks, does
football matter or
do restaurants matter
or does television matter?
So here are my questions.
How many people have to read a
poem to make it worth writing?
Do the people have to be
alive at the time the poem is
written?
Does it matter that the Super
Bowl will always have more fans
than any poem I write?
If you think maybe
it does matter,
do you apply this
capitalist mode of value
to everything in your life?
How impoverished would
your life be if you did?
Would poetry be more valued
if it cost more and took up
more space?
Isn't it cool that poetry
is the ultimate reality
show, a site for confusion,
ambivalence, complexity,
uncertainty, and big
and tiny feelings?
Isn't it cool that in a world
of increasing specialization,
a poet is the
ultimate generalist,
whose area is nothing
less general than what
it feels like to be human?
Could poetry have begun as
the chanting of vowel sounds
around a communal fire,
or by mothers to infants?
Which is more
important, your mother
singing to you or your mother
telling you to eat your beets?
Which came first?
Which is more
fundamental to you?
Which makes you human?
The poetry I love most,
as Judy so acutely pointed
out, partakes of song.
If you like music and
you like language,
you're the target market.
If a society doesn't
value poetry,
the most essential art--
I may be biased about that--
because it is solely made
from the very language that
makes us human, is poetry fucked
up or is the society fucked up?
Do we have other evidence
that our society is fucked up?
Is it possible
everything that can
be done is being
done to numb you
to the essential and
infinitely subtle
suffering and joy
of being alive?
Is it possible that
poetry wants to awaken
your awareness of the
essential and infinitely subtle
joy and suffering
of being alive?
Is it possible that poetry can
awaken you without telling you
exactly how?
Do we need to
discuss difficulty?
Is difficulty something
to discuss or something
to experience, or both?
Has your life been
without difficulty?
Do you know from difficulty?
Poems know from difficulty too.
Why shouldn't a poem create
a space for difficulty?
Paraphrasing the poet
Catherine Wagner,
do you like
understanding so much
you want it to
happen over and over?
Could it be that not
understanding or wondering
is more honest and even
less violent than knowing?
If you can't go that far, is
it possible at least every
once in a while?
Can something be difficult
and also a pleasure?
Could part of
poetry's difficulty
be that poems are
made from something
we've depended on
since toddlerhood
to communicate our basic needs?
Is it a little
disconcerting to encounter
a language that doesn't
have so much interest
in informational exchange?
Could it be OK that
language can be
used to communicate basic
physical and emotional needs,
and information, and also to
make crafted objects, i.e.
poems?
Some water you drink.
Some water you swim in.
Some water sprays up out
of an ornamental fountain.
Can you enjoy an art
form that uses language
like paint on a canvas?
Can you enjoy an art
form that uses language
like notes on a staff?
Can you enjoy an art
form that uses language
to make a frame for a
picture that never quite gets
hung at the museum?
Could it be OK to use
language to give pleasure?
Could this pleasure be
an act of resistance,
resistance against the
debasement of language?
Are you starting to
want some answers?
Here's one possible answer.
Poetry opens up
spaces for language
that echo through centuries.
Poetry is the fresh stream that
feeds the lake of language.
Other streams also
pour into the lake,
with waters not so
fresh and lively.
In fact, some of
the other streams
are dull or toxic or fake.
Poetry replenishes and
restores the lake of language.
Do you need fresh water only
under drought conditions,
or do you need it all the time?
Even if you don't drink directly
from the spring of poetry,
you drink from the
lake of language
the spring has
fed and sweetened.
Even if you don't read
poetry, I assure you
that poetry is whispering
to you and maybe
waiting for you to jump in.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
Thank you.
So now let's see if
I can walk the walk.
The first poem I'm going
to read is the first poem
I wrote here at Radcliffe,
in my office in Byerly Hall.
And I found that
because I suddenly
had such oodles
of time to write,
this poem rejected my usual
urge to compress and distill.
And instead, I allowed myself
to go on every tangent that
occurred to me and make lots
of long digressions, which
happen on the page
between parentheses,
so you'll hear them as
like frequent interruptions
in the poem's basic narrative.
And for anyone who is familiar
with Elizabeth Bishop's poetry,
the echoes of her that you
hear are very intentional.
It's called-- this is
maybe a little daring
to lead with a poem
called "On Boredom,"
but yes, my first poem
is called "On Boredom."
"One Saturday, Saturday
when my time comes,
among my last thoughts will
be that I did not fully
appreciate Saturdays.
My aunt Anne, who
died this month,
took me to my first Broadway
show, 'Fiddler on the Roof.'
She took me and five
cousins on an early morning
bus from the Albany Trailways
station to Port Authority.
She treated us to lunch,
and then to a matinee.
I ate fried chicken
for lunch, a food
I now abhor for reasons
of taste and ethics,
neither of my well-doing,
but products of the passage
of time and consciousness.
Then I was beguiled by the
red plastic basket where
the golden chicken rested, and
had an orange drink and Junior
Mints in the theater.
Of the show, I remember
'Matchmaker, Matchmaker,' and
how the three daughters found
their matches, true love,
which of course came with
the iconic problems, money,
religion, politics.
But we, the audience,
knew an inescapable pair
when we saw it.
I was only nine, but wished
that I could be a pair too.
What a limited life I had.
I was nine.
I didn't know any
Jews, though I'd later
marry a Jew, who
has sheltered me
from my chronic problems, who
has worked so I could work
on poems that don't earn money.
Sitting in the dark full of
chicken and sweetness made
me drowsy and dull, my
critical sense, such as it
was at nine, absolutely dulled.
To this day, I can't sit in
a theater and feel anything
but grateful to the
actors and musicians.
I have no critical sense.
This was not the
kind of boredom I
had felt the year before at the
Baseball Hall of Fame, where
my father, Aunt Anne's
brother, who has seen me
through life to this day,
has cushioned me through,
led me around a room filled
with nothing more entertaining
than three walls
of bronze plaques.
This was not that
kind of boredom.
It was boredom of my
will doing, abstracted
extravagance, a red velvet
cushion cocoon of mindlessness.
This sumptuous mindlessness
is what I cultivate
when I let a poem begin.
Unlike the show's
three daughters,
Aunt Anne was not a pair.
She was an unmarried
woman, considered pitiable
in that family and at that time.
She lived all her
life with her parents,
and after they died, alone.
She enjoyed theater
and gambling--
also took me to my
first bingo night--
and vivid conversations around
her mother's kitchen table,
later hers.
Every Sunday there I was,
bored by the grownup talk
and breathing secondhand
cigarette smoke.
What a limited life she had
with her fire and ice lipstick
and heavy gold bangles.
Didn't she have ambitions?
I think she was ambitious to
take six kids all that way.
Must ambitious-- must
ambition be performance?
Does ambition only count
if many people see?
Many needs defining.
And if the people aren't
your immediate family?
After the show, we boarded
a crowded Trailways bus
back home.
We kids were sleepy,
wired, and fractious.
The seats in pairs, I had to sit
next to a stranger, a man who
looked to a nine-year-old who
didn't know any professors
like a professor.
He wore dark-framed glasses
like my father's, a tweed cap.
The little pinpoint
light shone down on him.
He read first a magazine
and then a book.
He had a leather briefcase
full of books and magazines.
I had nothing to
read but my playbill.
I read front to back,
then back to front,
then started over again.
The man, although absorbed
in his own reading,
must have noticed, because he
took the magazine, National
Geographic, out from his
briefcase and gave it to me.
Maybe you'd like to
read this, he smiled.
In Citizen Kane, a movie
I watched with my father
and which didn't bore
me, the accountant
talks about seeing a woman in
a white dress one day when he
was 17, and then never again.
But not a month goes by
that I don't think of her.
This is supposed to
be a doleful mystery.
He only saw her once.
It's not mysterious.
It is perfectly clear.
The woman was his creation.
He conjured her from boredom.
Clarity, what use
are you to me now?
My mystery is this.
How many days were
blank of thought
about Aunt Anne, who
gave me this memory poem,
or about my father,
who gave me leisure
to think about my inner life
instead of about hardships
and displacement,
leisure to be bored.
Bored is a withdrawal
of attention.
Pay attention.
My aunt and cousins
in the back of the bus
were sleeping, snuffling
close but separate,
dreaming privately,
thrilling dreams probably,
for dreams are never boring,
unlike the magazine so
kindly offered but photo
of bleak hot desert,
photo of frozen
mountain, so boring.
My eyes were dim with sleepiness
and the strain of reading
in the dark and something else,
a look I carry to this day,
no matter what I'm reading, even
when I'm reading, that says,
hungry, hungry, please won't
you give me something to read?"
So the next two poems
I'm going to read also
have an early fall
semester connection.
Back in August I think
it was, I got an email
from Meg Rotzel asking me
to contribute something
to the gallery
exhibit that was meant
to showcase the work of
the incoming Fellows.
And I couldn't imagine
what I could possibly
send to her that she would want
to put on the wall of an art
gallery and told her so.
And she just sort of
persisted and encouraged
me to think of something
with a visual element.
And finally, I thought
of these next two poems.
They appear in my most
recent book, The Do-Over.
And they do have
a visual element,
because they're acrostics,
which mean that they spell out
the name of their subject.
They're part of a little suite
of elegies for famous people
that appear in the book, which
is an exploration of death
in a variety of forms.
Acrostics as a form were widely
used in 19th century mourning
poetry.
And they seem to form a
kind of like gravestone
on the page, a kind
of engraved monument
to the one who has gone.
And I'm going to show
you the first one now.
So you can see this is a
poem for Amy Winehouse.
And you can see how in the
left column if you read down,
it spells out her name.
And so the other
Radcliffe connection
with this poem and the
companion poem that goes with it
is that I've been working with
my research partner, Daniela
Muhleisen to translate
the book into Spanish.
And she has done
such an amazing job
of rising to the challenge of
putting up with my insistence
on complicated forms like this,
and also maintaining the music
and the content of these poems.
So I'm going to read
this one and then I'm
going to ask her to come up
and read the translation, which
you'll also see next, and
then another acrostic elegy
and the translation for that.
So "Amy Winehouse.
All song is formal and
you maybe felt this
and decided you'd be formal
too, the eyeliner, the beehive,
formal.
When a desire to escape
becomes formal, it's dangerous.
Then escape requires
nullity, rather than
a walk in the park or a movie.
Eventually, nullity gets
harder and harder to achieve.
After surgery, I had opiates.
I pushed the button
as often as I could.
Understood by music was
how I felt, an escape so
complete it became a song.
After that, elegy's the
only necessary form."
- Amy Winehouse.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
- And the next little
elegy is for Donna Summer.
"Discourse that night concerned
the warm-blooded love we felt.
On the divan in the bar room
and on the terrace, we felt it.
Now virtue meant liking the
look of the face we lay next to.
Never mind the staying
of the winter solstice.
All discourse that night
concerned the warm-blooded love
we felt. Something
lifted us higher,
her little finger told her so,
untangling with careless skill
the flora of the sexual grove.
Master physician
with a masterly joy
in wrapping up mud-spattered
coke-dusted wounds
at midnight, when it's too early
to stop dancing and go home.
Our lily-minds
soothed by her royalty
concealed in the synthesizers in
the flora of the sexual grove."
- Donna Summer.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
So the next poem
is what I spent--
or excerpts from what I spent
the bulk of last semester
writing, which is a long
diary poem based on notes
I had made last July
during a road trip
I took with my daughter.
It was the summer before
she went to college,
and we decided--
we're a family who
loves nutty road trips,
so we decided we
were going to drive
from the northernmost point in
the continental United States
to the southernmost point.
So I want to share a little
of that diary poem, which
turned out to be so much
more epic than I ever
dreamed it was going to be.
But that's the result
of having all this time.
It's clocking in right
now at around 50 pages.
There's an entry for almost
every day in July, 2016.
And the poem is
written in diary form,
with the date and the
location as headers.
There are prose sections,
sections written
in syllabic verse,
and some freestanding
poems with separate titles
that kind of act as lyric
interludes apart from or in
counterpoint to the diary
sections.
And because of the time,
July 2016, and the places,
basically the heart
of the United States
where we were traveling, it
is a mother-daughter story,
but it's also more.
And there is a lot of
political reverberations.
My daughter's name is Muriel,
and she's usually called Murie
in the poem and in real life.
And my husband's name
is Rob, and he was there
for part of the trip.
So July-- ooh.
Let me get rid of this.
"July 16th, Branson,
Missouri,"--
which I don't know if
anyone has ever been there,
but it's basically-- yeah.
It's basically the like
Las Vegas of the Ozarks.
So Branson, Missouri.
"I woke up to Rob's salty
smell and the fucking sun.
Replica of Empire State
Building topped by King Kong.
At first, I think it's
the World Trade Center
tower with its plume of smoke.
Replica of Titanic.
We're each given
a passenger's name
and have to wait until
the end of the tour
to find out whether we survive.
I survive.
Murie survives.
Rob, as a male crewmember,
doesn't survive.
Toy museum.
Quotes from Bible on walls.
BB gun annex,
segregated cabinets
with black Sambo and
Aunt Jemima dolls,
careless piles, dusty
board games, unloved dolls.
What I thought I had learned
about towns, where there
is money, towns are pleasant,
and where there is no money,
towns are unpleasant.
But there has to
be a quietness too.
We play mini golf, our family
sport, at Pirate's Cove."
And then here is one of
the standalone poems,
which is called "Mini Golf."
"The object of the game
is to be a family sport.
The object of a family
is to self-destruct.
Mini golf, like
a family, creates
its own artificial world.
Mini golf, like a family,
trades in myths and legends.
In both, there is the illusion
of individuality, club heights,
ball colors, contradiction,
rebellion, separation.
Both are at their most
intense in summer.
Money troubles tend
to disrupt each.
The mini golf boom of the early
20th century came to an end
during the economic
depression in the late 1930s.
Mini golf and
families are for those
who wish the past different.
Mini golf was invented
in the United States,
as was my family.
The object of the United
States is to self-destruct.
Can I prevent it with my
pink putter and orange ball,
driving into the
artificial sand trap
or farther, far into the myth of
the unblemished bloody summer?"
"July 25th, Key West, Florida."
That was our final destination.
"Posh white town with
a mask of slackerdom.
Somebody made the money.
Who and how?
Bernie addressing
the DNC now, a moment
that could or should have been.
Murie says they
all sound so fake.
I'm reading books of poetry
like they're clementines
and I have scurvy.
Spahr, Buffam, Schiff,
Mayer, white women.
There's whiskey in the jar,
Confederate flag on the car.
Roosters strutting
around Old Town
remind me of Elizabeth
Bishop's war poem, white women.
Walk to southernmost point.
Waves slap the
embankment and we slap
the concrete buoy monument.
Made it.
We produced by far the
most progressive platform
in the history of
the Democratic Party,
says Bernie, I am proud
to stand with her."
This is a little standalone
poem, "On Gender."
"I said to Murie
over key lime pie
that we need more
feminine energy in power
to challenge the patriarchy.
I meant Bernie.
She disagreed.
She doesn't think
anything is gendered.
I modified, nurturing energy
instead of dominating energy.
Then she could agree.
Are mothers always a
mystery to daughters?
I don't want to be.
July 26th, Key West, Florida.
Last night, the convention.
I was so dispirited
that I wanted
to open the bottle of $2 Chuck
the Miami Airbnb host left
and drink myself to sleep.
Today I'm more resigned.
And because we have to move on
into the future, I have hope.
Murie in pain from
her period today.
We did next to nothing,
late brunch and visit
to Hemingway's house.
Highlight, the six-toed
cats, of course.
Dropped Murie off
at our room, then
walked to Elizabeth
Bishop's house."
And this is a little poem
called "On Memory," and then
in parentheses, "On Poetry."
I couldn't decide.
It seems to fit both.
And the first line
is, "I remember it,"
and that refers to
Elizabeth Bishop's house
in Key West, which I walked to.
"I remember it from
2000 as a white house
with a very high
white fence around it.
Either someone took
down the fence or else
I'm misremembering, or maybe she
had two addresses in Key West.
And my poem about the house with
the sign about dog sweaters,"
found in my first book, "may
be a complete figment too.
No sign except for one
next to the front door
that said 'hippies use back
door' and a formal plaque
on the gate.
First I typed fate.
In the noiseless siesta
streets, lots of meaty
succulents, lots
of scattered stone.
I remember a story I heard about
Elizabeth Bishop and her lover
Louise Crane, how they bought
a house together in Key West
and then Louise went
back to New York
and Elizabeth wrote letter
to New York for her.
In your next letter, I wish
you'd say where you are going
and what you are doing.
And then Elizabeth's surprised
Louise by paying a bit a visit
and was in turn surprised
to find Louise in bed
with a musician friend.
When Elizabeth told
the story afterwards,
she named Billie Holiday.
Then I remember her poem
with the cringe-worthy title
"Songs for a Colored Singer."
The time has come to call
a halt, and so it ends.
Then I remember how tired
I am of sleeping alone.
Mary and I talked about
how to deal with her period
at college.
Like me, she has just
24 bad hours a month.
She said she'll just
go to her classes
and spend the rest of
the 24 hours in bed.
I tell her about tribes that
have separate huts where
menstruating women can be
outside of their daily lives,
be taken care of
by the other women.
They also stay in bed, swaddled
along with their newborns,
for a month after
they give birth.
That always sounded right to me.
Later we go out for ice cream,
sweat sluicing our backs.
I ask for chocolate
amaretto in a cone.
The depressed-looking manager,
a white guy around 60,
says, the flavors with alcohol
are too soft for cones.
I'm sure you know that
alcohol doesn't freeze,
a futile bit of information.
No, I didn't know.
But OK.
He looks at me blankly
and offers to accommodate,
ice cream in a dish
with cone stuck on top."
So the next poem is
outside of that diary poem.
It comes from the domestic
experience, which we probably
all had, of lifting
up a chair cushion
and finding objects
underneath it.
So I did that and
I took a picture,
and I posted it on Facebook.
And someone commented
that the picture looked
like a Joseph Cornell box.
And then I took a
closer look, and I
did find a kind of
coherence and emotion
in the grouping of objects.
So I'm going to
show you the photo.
Here we go.
[LAUGHTER]
So the poem is written
in a list form.
I list each object and then
do a little riff on it.
Don't judge me for my
poor housekeeping skills,
and my poor housekeeping
skills are in the poem,
so at least I'm honest about it.
And the poem is called "Found
Under a Chair Cushion."
"One, dark brown hair
tie, one of a set
once primly wrapped
around a card
in varying shades of brown meant
to match the ponytail of anyone
who wanders into the CVS.
I don't know what color
my hair is, so long have I
paid to have it painted
gold as an October leaf
when the pavement
is cool and wet.
Two, Mad Men DVD,
season 1, disk 1.
I tried to watch it.
I really did.
It turned into an elephant
lumbering toward me,
then it tiptoed like a Disney
elephant, eyeing me coyly.
But lumbering and
shilly-shallying are faddish.
I wanted a bullet,
express and true.
I've always been
a boy in that way.
The boys on the disk
are splendid and shaved,
in white shirts, courtiers
forming a circle around the sun
king.
While the velvet folds
of my spirit slept,
I tried to believe I owed
it to my generation to act
as a dutiful audience member.
In other words, even in the
presence of the sun king,
I tried being good,
but I got bored.
Three, flyer for
house-cleaning service.
Life's too short to
clean your own home.
I agreed and the
family flew apart,
couch flew apart, hand
towels flew apart.
Dust overwhelms the
lungs twice daily.
Homer, for example, has
never been out of print.
Is it because he lacked
ambition for the clean life?
Capitalism plus art plus
laziness, a dangerous formula.
Four, seven dimes and one penny.
Dimes are jewelry, pretty
beyond what monetary value
we endow them with.
With $0.71, I could buy
almost 3/4 of a Snickers bar,
but I'm off sugar.
$0.71 is what I'd need for 3 and
1/2 minutes of garage parking
on 12th Street, while I teach
the willing and unwilling
how to laugh and cry
about line breaks,
or the amount I earn for
every $1 earned by a man,
or shall I adorn myself
with coins, like a mad girl
in tatters?
Five, tweezer.
It is time.
It is time to wrench
out all the ugly hairs.
The sun king approaches.
[LAUGHTER]
Six, red-haired
Playskool plastic kid,
dressed in jeans and gray
hoodie, paint spattered.
This small person
appears to be angry,
having spent 10 years
under a chair cushion,
having first suffered abuse
during some long forgotten
crafts project.
He is furious, but
is nevertheless
giving me a thumbs-up."
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you for laughing.
So the next poem is an example
of l'esprit de l'escalier.
Some of you probably know that's
the French name for literally
"the wit of the staircase."
And it's the name for the
experience of thinking up
the perfect retort
for something only
after you've left the party
and are walking down stairs.
A couple of years
ago, I gave a reading.
And after the reading, a
poet who was in the audience
came up to me and said,
your poems are good.
Eccentric, but good.
And so if I had come up with
the perfect response to that,
I wouldn't have had
to write this poem.
The poem references
Emily Dickinson
and her habit of making little
crosses on her manuscripts
to denote alternative words.
So like she'd write a line and
put a little cross next to one
of the words.
And then somewhere
else on the page,
she'd put another little
cross with an alternate word.
So she didn't-- either
she didn't get around
to finalizing, or because she
wasn't planning to publish it
she didn't want to finalize,
or as I choose to think of it,
she just was really making great
use of that utterly free space
of the poem that I talked about.
And you'll see that
I too incorporate
multiple possibilities
for words in my poem.
It also has a quote
from Emily Dickinson,
which is something she
wrote in one of her letters.
"All men say what to me,"
meaning that she'd often
say something to a man and get
a response, what, like no one
understood her because
she was too brilliant.
And then there's a tad bit of
French in the first stanza,
so "un Francais" is a Frenchman.
And in the poem,
this Frenchman says,
"c'est chaud, hein," which
just means, "it's hot, right?"
"It's hot, isn't it?
So, "To the Poet Who After
My Reading Said, 'Your Poems
are Good.
Eccentric, But Good.'"
Imagine that you at 18, in Paris
for the first time with all
your loving ideals about penises
intact, in your new mini trench
coat and smelling the smell
of garlic and unfiltered smoke
and assaultive coffee, were
approached from behind.
Imagine un Francais,
bald, smooth, spectacled,
grabbed your right hand and
pressed it to his yes soft yes
exposed penis, and hissed,
'c'est chaud, hein?'
as he kept walking
past you shaking
with his poor French
demented laughs.
Would you say trauma?
It wasn't.
Would you think poem fodder?
Would you bring to bear
your rhetoric textbook
and wall of metaphors
built up from yes stone
yes sky yes Shakespeare?
You no not arrogant mentioned
your encroaching baldness,
which I said that I yes liked.
You were not spectacled nor
smooth, but admire, I think,
smoothness.
You didn't want to say bad.
You couldn't commit to good.
Smoothly, the
current does not run.
Smoothness can never shock.
When electricity
veins through the sky,
is that really its best,
it's crispest manifestation?
Must Emily Dickinson ride
through the yes cloud-dark sky
on a flashing bolt, screaming
'all men say what to me?'
Hands tattooed with
the small crosses
that meant she couldn't choose,
settle on an ideal word.
Abandoned possibility fairer
than prose for a what, word?
Imagine this same hot lightning
snaking up your rectum.
That was childbirth,
14 hours hard work.
And my husband's
smell and my cow
moans and the doula's
watered-down grape juice
helped.
I couldn't call it pain, no.
Orgasm, no.
Earthquake, closer, but no.
But I wanted so to
call it something.
This is the merry
disease we share.
I suspected that
the Queen's English
and I would not run smoothly
then, so I wept past imagining.
Is it possible that death
will be a yes, immortality not
a marble stone but
a what, maxipad?
A silver perfume?
There is no yes true metaphor,
each eccentric as the others.
When I dab my wrist and neck
with the oily rollerball
of my favorite perfume
essence, Rain by Terranova,
a bargain at yes less
than $20 for 0.3 ounces,
notes of lily of the
valley, clover, and musk,
I do it because it smells
fresh, like a new earth.
Imagine that same
lightning struck you down
on the new earth dead.
You'd say critical judgment.
I'd say poor social skills.
Imagine instead the lightning
struck the earth and a laurel
bloomed where once
stood only tombstones.
I know it's hard to
be a man with an ideal
between your legs, and
nothing but Shakespeare's
cold lightning waiting
for you on Judgment Day.
Let's wait together.
We open our hearts
and dictionaries.
You were waiting, weren't you,
for me to say, gee, thanks,
and are still what
yes no waiting?"
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So this is the last poem.
And it's an example, I think,
of a poem that song-like.
I've always been obsessed with
the idea of radical inclusion,
the idea of making a poem that
I could put everything in.
So that's impossible,
but I do keep trying.
And this is a poem where
I was trying to do that.
And it's just called "Go,"
so I send you forth with it.
"It is a cube.
It is red.
It is mountainous.
It is a bird of fire.
It is the bones of the pelvis.
It is a walnut.
It is treasured.
It is yellow Saturn,
wobbling in its orbit.
It is danger squawking.
It is the desire to sit down
with strangers in cafes,
and then it is the
strangers in cafes.
It is the man with the
black t-shirt labeled
'unarmed civilian,' and it is
the blind man with him and his
painful trembling.
Always it is oxygen and more
oxygen. It is the fight in you
and the fight in you dying.
It is the need for water and the
water that falls from the sky.
It is desperate
for a theory and it
is the acts you call
evil when you know there
is no evil, only desperation.
It is that bravery, that
arrogance, that blindness.
It is the pink morning and
your smile in the pink morning.
It is a phantom and a
thin neck of a tree.
It is a little project
called loving the world.
It is howling in the dirt.
It is an extravaganza.
It's the abandoned sports bra
in the dirt beside howling you.
It's the wind chimes
in the thin-neck tree
and it is tongue-tied.
It is asleep.
It is waking up now.
It is a small cat on the bed.
It is the threads
of the leaf and it
is the three graces, splendor,
mirth, and good cheer.
It is their heartfelt advice.
You can't let it hurt you.
You're must let it hurt you.
It is a careless error and the
hotel pool blue with chemistry.
It's a kiss.
Of course it is a kiss.
It's an old strange book, newly
acquired but not yet cataloged.
It is crazy.
It is you crazy with honesty
and crazy with ambition.
It's the sun that stuns
over and over again.
It's your tablet, which is
every tablet everywhere.
It's an explosion.
It is every
explosion everywhere.
It is pavement, mineral and
hot, and wet with droplets.
It's the stars that pitch
white needles into the pond.
It is provable.
It is a lotion.
It is a lie.
It is a baby, because
everyone is a baby.
It talks to you, always to you.
It moves swiftly.
It is stuck.
It's the impenetrable
truth, now clear as ice.
It is serious.
It is irreversible.
It is going, going.
It is flying now,
laughing, strong enough
to know anything."
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]